you had a baby four months ago yeah four
months and four days
beautiful girl beautiful little girl and
how's it going so far I mean it's such a
mind altering change it's the greatest
thing that's ever happened to me I've
said this and and I stand by it
it is great yeah yeah absolutely
fantastic I saw a red-carpet picture of
you and it looked like Channing Tatum
was staring at ya because there are
changes that the body goes through and
it looks like he's busted for staring at
my breasts
that's awful here's the thing he swear I
know him and I love it he really wasn't
but boy do these things grow yeah I I I
don't know how to deal with them because
I've never had them inside always
dressed for a flat-chested girl and I
was setting them busty and I'm like whoa
check it out like I hey this is amazing
to me it's a whole new world it's a
whole new world well people were yeah
they don't they don't react to you
differently differently do they no they
do like men actually look at my boobs
I've never had that happen before
because they're just they're like I'm
just staring so hard at your forehead
right now
oh I wouldn't go down there stupid I'm
picturing like the cartoons with the
eyes come out of that Wow
well do you does it I mean you must feel
differently you must move differently
when you have the larger chestal area
hey mom yeah no no you do well I used to
dress differently well first of all I
needed to start wearing bras that was a
whole new experiment for me I was like
what are these things that people wear
right right now I have to yeah
you